foreign
I like to think of the voyage and canoes
is taking us back in time on the ocean
the Hua kamalu is a navigator with the
Polynesian voyaging Society I'll often
ask my crew like what do you think it
would have been like to show up in
Hawaii as the very first navigator the
first canoe and and imagine sort of a
stunning nature that we would have seen
because of course Hawaii has changed
since we since we found it and then
since we've been here but yes I think we
think of the early Navigators more often
than people probably realize
lihua and her fellow Navigators don't
use maps or modern instruments to
navigate across the ocean they use the
Stars ocean waves and other natural
signs to guide them a method that
pacific voyagers have used for thousands
of years known as wayfinding it's a
broadly wayfinding uh for us really is
that idea that with the naked eye with
all of your senses with your complete
abilities
to immerse yourself in to the signs of
the natural world that are around you
leaning on the learnings and the
knowledge of our ancestors and all the
people who have come before us we have
so much knowledge and ability to use
that information to find our way on
canoes and as we travel across the ocean
where there are no street signs
navigates aboard a Polynesian voyaging
canoe called Hokulea Hokulea translates
to the star of gladness and it's a large
double-haul canoe 62 feet long with
triangular Crab Claw sales this is the
style of the sailing vessels that the
Hawaiians voyaging ancestors use to
travel between islands in the Pacific
we have all of these like modern
modern Comforts that help us out these
days you know and yet still I always say
gosh our ancestors were either way more
rugged and tough than us or way smarter
or all of the above to be able to do
these voyages in those times
[Music]
I'm Eli Chen senior editor of audio Nash
and this is overheard a show where we
eavesdrop on the wild conversations we
have here at Nat Geo and follow them to
the edges of our big weird beautiful
world
this week we're setting sail with
National Geographic Explorer lahua
kamalu she'll tell us what it's like to
spend weeks out on the open ocean
retracing the roots of our ancestors as
well as the harrowing and Sleepless
Journey she took on her first voyage as
Captain
and we'll talk about her next big
adventure a four-year voyage that will
take her crew to dozens of communities
around the Pacific out at Sea the ground
is moving
everything's moving so before you leave
you really need to get familiar with all
the things that might be out there and
then be ready to totally not have any
idea what you're gonna find
more after this
[Music]
but first Adventure is never far away
with a free one-month trial to National
Geographic premium for starters there's
full access to our stories online with
new ones published every day plus every
Nat Geo issue ever published is in our
digital archives
there's a whole lot more for subscribers
and you can check it out for free at Nat
geo.com Explore More
[Music]
centuries ago early Polynesians used
wayfinding to discover New Zealand
Hawaii Rapa Nui also known as Easter
Island and to navigate between islands
in the Pacific but following Captain
Cook's arrival in Hawaii during the 16th
century and later the U.S annexation of
the islands in 1886 colonization
suppressed Hawaiian cultural practices
and Native people eventually lost
wayfinding knowledge
in the 20th century Western thinkers
circulated and published their ideas for
how they believed people settled in
Polynesia that included Andrew sharp and
his accidental drift theory claiming
that early Polynesians accidentally
drifted to rapanui and other Islands
there is also Thor hiredal and The
Voyage of the contiki which tried to
prove that ancient humans sailed West
from South America to colonize the
islands Hawaiian culture Scholars say
theories like these discredited the
navigational skill and achievements of
early Polynesians
then in the 1970s there was this
cultural Renaissance among the Hawaiian
community that was focused on Reviving
the native language performing music in
hula and teaching Hawaiian culture to
younger Generations you can actually
hear the voices of this movement in the
1977 National Geographic TV special
Voyage of the Hokulea
in
are coming back to my game and unity
that's what we need is Unity come on you
Hawaii's to our great great ancestors
that we have never known
the Revival of Polynesian voyaging was
very much a part of this Renaissance the
idea to build Hokulea came from artist
herb Kane who also appears in the Nat
Geo TV special
in his Studio a Hawaiian artist Paints
the images of a past that now seems as
insubstantial as dream
but one time expatriate illustrator in
Chicago herb Kane has returned to the
islands with a dream of his own to
recreate a Polynesian voyaging canoe and
following the supposed path of ancestral
Mariners sail from Hawaii to Tahiti and
back
along with Anthropologist Ben Finney and
sailor Tommy Holmes Kane founded the
Polynesian voyaging Society with the
mission of demonstrating that early
Polynesians were intentional voyagers
and purposefully settled in Hawaii and
other parts of the Polynesian Triangle
but in the 1970s there were no living
Hawaiians with wayfinding knowledge so
if any Enlisted the help of Mao pialuk a
master navigator from the island of
satawal in Micronesia
schooled in ancient methods of
navigation by star and ocean swell it is
Pierce Mao pialug who must try without
instruments to guide Hokulea to Tahiti
across 3 000 miles of Open Sea Mao has
voyaged alone across hundreds of miles
of empty ocean guided only by the
computer in his mind
on May 1st 1976 the crew embarked from
Honolulu Bay in Maui and made it to
papayete Harbor in Tahiti four weeks
later on June 4th thousands of people
cheered for their arrival
foreign
I think the meaning of the canoe is is
very deep and Powerful here in Hawaii
and across Polynesia and Beyond I think
it it heralded a time that
I think marked a space where everyone
was able to remember how amazing and how
incredible the history of this place was
and that was a marked difference from
you know I think the decades prior where
there was this continuous
removal of culture and practice and
traditions the Hua kamalu was born in
New York to parents who were both part
native Hawaiian when she was little they
moved to Honolulu and enrolled lahua and
her sisters in a Hawaiian immersion
program where the curriculum was taught
in the native Hawaiian language and I
think Hokulea is sort of not just the
visual physical symbol of that that we'd
like to talk about here but really just
this living manifestation of of a
reminder that you come from great people
in a wonderful history
lahua says she thought of the voyaging
canoes as the space shuttle of her
Pacific ancestors and she remembers what
it was like when she and her classmates
got to visit the Hokulea after it
returned from a voyage in 1992.
and our whole school went to go greet it
at the beach when it returned from a
very long Voyage down to the Cook
Islands back through Tahiti and so not
only did we learn about it by watching
videos in class and reading about it we
actually got to go down and touch the
canoes and see them in action so it was
it was really inspiring and it has
always really been
um
something that I think a lot of us grew
up admiring admiring from a distance
mostly but the reality was it was right
there in our backyard and how amazing
that we get to be so close to this thing
when lahua grew up and went to college
she studied mechanical engineering and
she also started getting involved with
the Polynesian voyaging Society
I was like you know I have some nerdy
skills
maybe that can maybe that can help you
guys and that progressed rapidly into
the training getting out on the water I
had never really gone sailing much at
all before before that really um learn
learning all the ins and outs of how a
sailing vessel worked the engineering of
it and then I think I started to see
sort of engineering and everything that
I was doing I was like you know this is
exactly all the things that I'm
passionate about in my in my studies and
my Academia and it's it's really not
that far away
from where I thought I was headed and
layer on to that what I knew was a huge
impact on on Hawaii and its community
and its children so it just it's slowly
it slowly washed over in waves over the
course of years I would say yeah so help
us imagine what it's like to be you know
on one of these canoes sure
um
as I mentioned so hokuleta is sort of
the example I'll use she's a very
special canoe and and special to
everyone because she really was the
first built in modern times
this is a double hold vessel so each
hole is 62 feet long and they're
identical and they're lashed together
with eight cross beams we call them
iyako that tie together both holes we
call it the precursor to the modern
catamaran and so some people will say
hey what's that catamaran you guys say
I'm like ah well it's kind of it's kind
of a big sister
and you know we like to think and we
don't have what people would say
probably is more traditional in terms of
sleeping in a Halle or a house that sits
at the center of the deck we've sort of
adapted it so that you actually sleep on
the holes themselves
um a little bit of a canvas that
hopefully keeps out some of the Sun and
some of the waves and the rain but not
super effectively sometimes depending on
yeah so you're really exposed to the
elements it sounds like you are
absolutely pretty exposed and uh
something I always tell new people is if
you want to sort of experience what it's
like
you can just kind of maybe go stand
outside
and then just stay out there
for like a day and then a night and then
a day and then a night and just kind of
stay outside in your yard for like three
weeks straight and
um I my very first voyage I did not have
a good respect for how much sun that
actually was and uh you know I was
almost unrecognizably dark when I came
back
um I think I was almost matching with my
mom who's uh very lovely and dark but uh
and it is it's very exposed and a lot of
times just being on board and sort of
doing your day-to-day things is very
uncomfortable right every single task
involves being in an uncomfortable
position or holding on so you don't get
you know knocked down as the waves hit
the canoe going to the bathroom using
you know taking a shower you just sort
of you do that you do that in front of
everybody
in the early days you did
um we've developed sort of a more uh and
now that we have much more diversity on
board
[Laughter]
particularly me we have a little private
area that you can take care of all of
your business and that's towards the the
rear of the canoe we have a little like
cute little curtain that you can use but
everyone is is respectful of it you just
let us know where you are and I will
talk to you if you're using the restroom
area because uh just making sure you're
still connected to the canoe it's a very
dangerous place to be where people can't
see you and we're going very fast on the
ocean so I'm curious how wayfinding
works out on the sea how do you know
where to go when you don't have a GPS or
even a compass
the most popular example that will be
brought up in way finding is
understanding really strongly the
heavens above
um the celestial sphere if you will the
layout of all of the constellations and
stars in the sky and you don't have to
know all the astronomical information
about all of them but you need to know
how to find them where they are where
they are in relation to one another what
sort of paths they take as they rise and
set across the sky which changes by your
by your latitude
easiest example is always uh mintaka
which is sort of the first star that'll
rise in the belt of Orion and we have
different names for them
in Hawaiian
um I'd say if you wanted to give
yourself the minimum amount of time to
be ready to see the stars in The Right
Way start one year before your Voyage is
going to happen and understand how the
sky is moving as you look out every
night so when you don't have the Stars
though like when it's like during the
day and the sun is out like what what do
you look for
um you have the sun you have the Sun
from before Sun up till sun down you
have the dawn Sky you have
probably your most reliable thing which
is the ocean itself if you're sailing
hopefully you're on the ocean hopefully
hopefully you're uh in an ocean that
also has wind I know that sounds super
obvious but some days we just have no
wind and no waves and we just sit there
um and that's just something that
happens when you're when you're sailing
anyone who sails will appreciate that
but waves are governed by wind and waves
create regular readable patterns in the
ocean that are long range and very
consistent particularly in the tropics
particularly here in Polynesia and are
very reliable to find your way it means
you're constantly needing to pay
attention to them each hour and through
the night and so the Navigator's job is
to spend as little time
sleeping as possible and as much time
watching for consistency watching for
patterns in the sky and in the in the
ocean
and also for changes and comparing
what's going on between the two yeah
um just do looking at Birds helps at all
and like looking at wildlife
yes
um birds are very special and in fact
when we start to get closer to land it's
really the land-based birds that guide
us to their islands and so it's another
thing that you are looking carefully for
when you approach them also know what
not to follow others it's important to
know what birds are are followable and
not followable yeah because you know
you're you have pelagic Birds you have
birds that sleep at Sea and so you might
follow them but they might not get to
land for like two to four years so if
you've got enough Provisions uh by all
means enjoy the journey but uh you want
to stick to the ones and the specific
ones I'm thinking about are our turns
they live on land they either live in
the trees or in the rocks or on the
beaches and these they go home every day
you want to find the birds that um are
reliably like back home for supper
if you will
[Music]
Legend has it that long ago Pele the
Hawaiian goddess of fire sailed on a
canoe from Tahiti to Hawaii opening up a
route between the islands but even
though folklore depicts a woman
navigating by canoe to Hawaii Polynesian
voyaging has traditionally been passed
down from Grandfather to grandson and
since the first voyage to Tahiti in 1976
the hokulea's journeys have been
captained and largely navigated by men
that was until 2018 when the Polynesian
voyaging Society planned to sail
hokalea's sister canoe the hikianalia
2800 miles from Hawaii to California
with the organization to meet with
members of the muigma oloni tribe in San
Francisco to ask for permission to
arrive before the voyage and on the
flight home I literally remember looking
out the window of the weinerlands flight
at the ocean
coast of California and you could still
see the ocean from the window and it was
wild like the waves were super crazy
there was white water and whitewash you
could tell it was very windy and very
rough down there and I think I said I I
I turned to my co-worker and said wow
I'm so glad I'm not having to do this
Voyage because that looks so rough down
there I wouldn't want to be in that
which of course is going to haunt me
later on because then we go home and my
teacher and I know what Thompson he says
I
I'm gonna ask you to Captain this Voyage
um
which is a huge huge honor and and
responsibility and I instantly thought
of that picture I took in my mind raging
ocean off of San Francisco I was like oh
oh that way and I remember without like
almost skipping a p i was like I'll take
it all the way up there if you take it
the rest of the way through that because
I'll take it through the calm Waters uh
that that of course is was not part of
the deal and uh I had to I think sit
with it for a little while before
accepting that because
um
a little bit of it I think is convincing
yourself that you're ready to do this
um it seems always sometimes in this
world people can see that
possibility and that potential before
maybe I have but the journey itself was
both spectacular and terrible all at
once because those exact ocean
conditions that I had joked about on the
airplane were what we got when we
arrived yeah so what what was it like
when you were out in the water and
dealing with all that
um
so this is actually the first voyage of
the Polynesian voyaging Society had ever
sent a canoe into the North Pacific uh
to the West Coast and we leave out of
Honolulu we're in a little place called
kehi
we circle around the east side of the
island around diamond head around makapu
and we head up and our plan is to go
straight North as long as we need to
until we can get
some wind behind us in what's sort of
the North Pacific High the high pressure
system so the route and the plan and the
navigation is to take us up North and
then tack East and then find our way to
California the first about nine days I
would say were perfect wind perfect
weather
clear skies no rain we caught fish every
single day I was almost it was Blissful
very surreal uh Dolphins playing on the
bow day in and day out just on schedule
they were there it was like The
Breakfast Club of dolphins and then we
have to sort of cut our way over this
high pressure system which is very hard
to do in the middle of these wind
systems you get lulls sort of like Giant
Eyes of hurricanes but obviously not the
intensity of hurricanes so we have very
very low wind and we're moving
at like one and a half to two knots like
we could walk that faster
you could probably just get out and and
crawl that fast and so it's very slow
going but still with good weather uh and
the whole way we are practicing and we
are training young Navigators as we go
this is now nine days 10 days 12 days 15
days 19 days into the voyage
and we're getting closer and closer to
California partly because like I said
we've been keeping track of where we
came from how fast we've been going how
far how long and what direction and
we're honing in on what we think of San
Francisco Bay
and in a matter of about 12 hours we go
from Full sales sailing really fast
having a great time to okay it's now a
much heavier wind condition it's very
strong and the waves are starting to
build we have to Reef down the sails so
just close them up a little bit more so
that you're not catching as much wind
and it's not pushing you as fast you do
it little by little and so I'm like okay
close the back Sale close the front sail
okay let's just go on on this little
tiny storm sale that we have we are
going as slow as possible and I said we
average five knots as slow as possible
in these wind conditions where the
oceans the sea was about I'd say 20 25
feet
reasonably and the wind was at about 20
25 knots and for us that was very not
fun
um yeah it sounds like a roller coaster
it is it's a roller coaster if someone
took the roller coaster and smushed it
closer together so that the the Downs
are much more down and the UPS are much
more up oh man
and uh these were the harshest
conditions I had ever been on that canoe
with that I'd ever sailed with and
there's a little bit of maybe the
internal you know you are the captain of
this ship and you need to have a plan
for whatever happens and there's this
realization at some point of you know
your role and also to some degree
the futility you have in certain
situations uh there's only so much you
can do to react to what's going on and
you just have to make make your best
course uh there was there was a lot
going on and so it was a couple days of
severe
you know storm level winds and waves and
we took a lot of waves over over the
deck over the canoe
um one of my crew just trying to get up
and out to get on his watch to be able
to steer and do all of that was badly
injured a few broken bones and the whole
time I know we are very close to
California it's like where is this thing
like where is the end and just like that
it's almost like the movies where you
know the clouds part and the Sun comes
out and we're in the pristinely calm
flat Half Moon Bay
um
so I was like how did that happen you
know and it's morning time and we we
emerge from this this weather
um it it was incredible and we had been
up a lot of folks for a couple of days
by that point we were exhausted there
were greeting canoes and boats that were
coming out to see us that were expecting
us and we have a little tracker thing so
they were watching us come along and and
it's sort of this exhausted Joy when you
arrive and uh
you immediately transition out of this
voyage that was you that was your team
that was this canoe too all right now
what are we doing
for this community and so even though
you're exhausted
we will do any number of things to make
sure that that we are we allow them to
welcome us properly and and that we have
these ceremonies that are very special
and important and cultural exchanges and
it wasn't until we arrived in San
Francisco that you know a little girl
came up to me and said you know I want
to take my picture with you the first
woman Captain Navigator and I'm looking
at my crew like what like who who's
running this narrative here the first
you know Woman Counts I'm just I'm just
the captain Navigator
um and they're like no no you're the
first woman she was so sweet I like gave
her my hat and it was this really cute
moment that I remember of
um
you know maybe accepting uh where you
are in life and and remembering uh
those that are looking at the example
that you're setting and what it means to
do this and I usually take a long time
to get to that point probably the few
months after getting home from that
Voyage to reflect on the meaning of it
uh in that way
[Music]
it is it is Saturday
April 30th 2022. all right this is day
12 of our Voyage of Kelly Kahiki from
Hawaii to Tahiti
it has been a good day getting back
easting that we in 2022 the Hua and her
crew sailed the two sister canoes to
Tahiti retracing the route that Hokulea
traveled during its maiden voyage nearly
50 years earlier it took them about
three weeks to travel roughly 3 000
miles to Tahiti
I asked lahua about the kind of
conversations she had with the tahitians
when they arrived
the first were very special they were
honoring our relationship
um the long-standing relationship that
Hokulea has had to connect these two
Island spaces and honoring the leaders
um
honoring that they are that we are
trying to carry forward the tradition to
a new generation it's important that if
this voyaging is going to continue
that the next generation is connecting
to these people and places because you
know this isn't an organization and a
canoe that goes from Island to Island
these are people connecting to people
and those relationships carry on well
past the voyage itself so there's a lot
of recognition of that Heritage there
are groups that come with us from Hawaii
to celebrate that
and so there's a lot of work that goes
on to ensure that everyone understands
that we are one of the same people
um that usually takes a couple of days
actually and usually involves ceremonies
and and things of that nature and then
we get into the why we're sailing today
Beyond just the perpetuation of our
practice and Beyond reconnecting with
family and a realization that as one
family sharing this house of the Pacific
there are things that are affecting us
equally across the ocean and so one
event that was actually
um coinciding with our arrival there was
the blue climate Summit and that allowed
us to get into conversations about
what was going on in the oceans and all
of the different ways that our
communities are reacting to or trying to
proactively address these situations you
know we sail we go out on the ocean
we're the ones actually living on these
these sea roads what is our
responsibility to that as people who
live on these islands what are we doing
with our economies and our tourism and
our agriculture our Fisheries
to think about whether or not these
oceans are going to be healthy for our
children to be sailing in and so these
discussions happen alongside
these recognitions of unity and family
and they're very powerful because most
of it will invoke stories of memories of
what life was like what the abundance of
the sea was like and growing in our
understanding of what it means to be a
leader on the ocean and back in the
community again you know speaking of I
guess finding that Unity among Pacific
communities you know when this interview
comes out you'll be about to embark on a
circumnavigation of the Pacific so tell
us about that Journey how far and how
long is this Voyage expected to be yep
we are headed out again
um I'll find no shortage of reasons to
to voyage across the ocean so we're
going to be starting our next Voyage
it's called Moana
yeah it's a long wine word but it really
is meant to honor this one ocean and
people that doesn't have to be
specifically in the Pacific Ocean but
that is where this journey is going to
take us so we're going to be starting in
Alaska in June of this year and make our
way around and across the ocean Port by
Port yeah so you're starting in Alaska
you see you're starting pretty cold
actually yeah we're starting we're
starting in Alaska in the only time we
could reasonably go to Alaska and so
um our last the last time we had a bunch
of Hawaiians up there on a canoe was was
1995 which was reminiscent of how our
relationship Alaska began it's very
special and what ultimately happened was
when we talk about the traditional
materials that allow us to build these
these vessels of Discovery and
exploration and these canoes
um Hawaii back in the the late 80s tried
to build a second canoe chocolate
with all of the traditional materials
and trees and plants and with all the
Artisans that would have been needed in
the in the ancient past and there was a
realization that they were gone and a
lot of work has happened since then to
revitalize the actual land and realizing
that canoes are really the healthy
products of healthy communities and
islands and Alaska
stepped in and and to help and say we
will gift you two trees from our
children from the forests of Southeast
Alaska and those were sent down to
Hawaii to build a canoe that is now
Hawaii
and that celebrates this this beautiful
relationship that started with Alaska
and so we are actually starting off in
the birthplace of three of the elders
who made that happen and uh yes it is
going to be cold I'm a little worried
about the cold uh we're gonna bring some
of our Alaskan crew as well to join us
on that Journey
um but that will be sort of the launch
that takes us for the next three years
around the Pacific through Central South
America through our South Pacific
Islands Back to the Island of our our
teacher and Navigator maupai look and
all the way back up and around into to
Asia to Japan yeah that's so exciting
um
I've read that one of the goals for this
Voyage is to educate 10 million
Navigators I'm wondering what that means
exactly and how that would be
accomplished
yeah the word educated education always
seems to do one of two things get people
really inspired or like they turn around
and say oh gosh education so yeah I
think Navigators come in come in all
different types and we might be you know
traditional wayfinding Navigators of
canoes but a lot of the
I think the value sets and the
priorities and the ways that we are able
to conduct these voyages and these
canoes and Lead these Crews on these
voyages
are are relevant to someone who might
just be trying to navigate some part of
their life or a project or community and
this is both a celebration of those
Navigators and and finding those 10
million Navigators but also allowing a
pathway for people to find their way
into Navigators I always feel like
there's almost this direct
Synergy and overlap with with what we
appreciate and Joy about explorers
um and layered into that the ability to
dive into your own culture your own
history your own practice and have a
unique way of navigating unto yourself
foreign
if you want to learn more about the
Polynesian voyaging Society head to
their website which is Hokulea
h-o-k-u-l-e-a.com and you can read more
about the hokalea's 2022 journey to
Tahiti in a piece that writer Jordan
Salama reported for Nat Geo that's all
in the show notes right there in your
podcast app this week's overheard
episode is produced by Kyrie Douglas and
me Eli Chen our senior producers are
Brian Gutierrez and Jacob Pinter our
manager of audio is Carla Wills who
edited this episode our executive
producer of audio is tavar ardalon our
photo editor is Julie Howe hansdale
Sue's sound design this episode and
composed our theme music the voyaging
tape you heard was shared with us by the
Polynesian voyaging Society this podcast
is a production of National Geographic
Partners the National Geographic Society
committed to illuminating and protecting
The Wonder of our world funds the work
of National Geographic Explorer lahua
kamalu
Michael Tribble is the vice president of
integrated storytelling Nathan lump is
National Geographics editor-in-chief and
I'm your host and Senior editor Eli Chen
thanks for listening and see you next
time
[Music]
foreign